in the heart of the Medina 75 kilometers
away from the epicenter desperation
volunteers distribute medicine to those
who have lost their homes painkillers
insulin and basic first aid Necessities
all donations
help from the government is too slow to
come they say
they have no homes they are sick and the
only help is from charity
for Marrakesh this is a moment of unity
in the face of an unprecedented calamity
we have to stand together
the devastation spans across six
provinces many are hard to reach areas
Rubble is blocking the roads making the
search and rescue operation difficult
I have lost 10 members of my family and
they're still under the rubble
as the hours go by the chances of
finding survivors is diminishing and the
death toll keeps rising
at the hospitals doctors are overwhelmed
treating the injured more keep coming in
and blood is running out
from Qatar to Spain help is arriving
they come with sniffer dogs and thermal
imaging cameras
the government has announced an
emergency program aimed at
rehabilitating and providing support to
construct homes in the areas affected by
Devastation additionally Provisions have
been made for expenses associated with
assisting vulnerable individuals
particularly orphans and those in
fragile situations immediate assistance
is also allocated for people without
shelter
in the Medina the clearing up has
started in what seems a perilous
operation we follow a resident returning
to his home to assess the damage
this is a traditional kitchen you can
see that people just left in hurry and
the ground here is undulated it's as if
there are waves underneath the flooring
and I want to show you how narrow the
staircase is
simply too dangerous for this family
that lives here to come back in their
home
foreign
t and a few bottles of water
food for those who cannot return home
yet again they will spend the night
huddled together with a fear of another
Tremor unsure of what tomorrow will look
like
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera Marrakesh
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera